well with so many people enjoying the
spring weather by hiking safety is
always top of mind when you are heading
Outdoors earlier today we sent Mary Jane
beliesza to the trails with Red Rock
search and rescue for advice on keeping
everybody safe
Southern Nevada has a vast range of
beautiful hiking trails and Craig
McVeigh knows how instant a simple hike
can turn deadly two things they either
underestimate Mother Nature or they
overestimate their own capabilities
they is the Pio for Red Rock search and
rescue and all volunteer and self-funded
funded helping local agents Seas across
Southern Nevada find missing people
we've actually done a couple searches
right right through these Trails one of
a young lady she she perished on the
trail
with the team taking on over 40 cases a
year he knows how precious time is
during a rescue he says the biggest
mistake he sees among hikers is not
being prepared we can typically within
an hour and a half to two hours get a
team get teams into the field and here's
a very basic bag McVay says you should
pack essential items such as a first aid
kit a pocket knife flashlight and an
emergency Beacon staying hydrated is key
and don't wait to drink water before you
get thirsty if you're going to be going
up to one of these even these small
Peaks here you're talking four to six
gallons of water throughout the day and
if you get lost Don't Panic sit down
take a moment have some water maybe eat
something look at your situation think
through what you've done where you've
been and it's not just enough to be
prepared during your hike but before
your hike that means knowing your body
limits and stretching and making sure
you're wearing the proper clothing and
gear before you hike
do not have a plan for what you're going
to do and where you're going to go that
you give to a responsible person who
knows what to do you have not set
yourself up for Success if something
goes wrong